I've had my eyes my sclera stained I've
got a flesh tunnel I've had a tongue
split
he's modified almost every inch of his
body and willingly paid to have it done
but in the eyes of the law he's a victim
of a man who reveled in the nickname dr.
evil we all gave full consent we were
all happy he gave us consultation and
talked to us for the procedure we knew
he wasn't a doctor despite playing on
the Austin Powers name of dr. evil we
were very happy with him he's one of the
best in the country Brendan McCarthy
used to run dr. Evil's body modification
Emporium very openly four years from
this premises in Wolverhampton city
centre he was registered for tattooing
and piercing but his offerings became
more and more extreme and that's what
led to his nickname
you know the surgical gloves
scalpel on the screen account of elbow
the council got a tip that he was
chopping off people's ears
sheera Brendan believes he's an artist
however one he's not qualified to carry
out surgical procedures to his premises
are in no fit and proper state to carry
out surgical procedures and three more
importantly something would have gone
wrong Brendan could not have dealt with
that emergency McCarthy admitted three
counts of grievous bodily harm in what
is the first case of its kind I
absolutely agree with the fact that the
law is too restrictive as it stands of
disallowing body modifications I think
we do need to draw a line somewhere but
we need to recognize that people should
be allowed to adapt their own bodies as
they see fit Alex wanted her tongue
split by dr. evil she's now booked to
have it done abroad he's very like
well-respected in
you know but legally is frowned upon now
so no one will offer procedures like
that because of their own safety humans
have been modifying their look for
thousands of years
now local councils and those who do this
want clarity on just how far they can go